i appreciate you talking about this
i had so much fun with it after loving
the first season it's always nice when
you love
the second season because you never know
and i was very happy but i loved the
second season
we're happy to hear that too well i i'm
curious because this show was not
based on source material no one knew who
these characters would be or what to
expect from them
the audience went into this first season
with no expectations
so when did you guys realize how much of
a success the show
had become and that it was actually
connecting with people globally
i don't know if i'll really ever kind of
understand the gravity of how popular it
is
i think you talk about like 50 million
viewers for the first season and
i don't know if i'll ever really truly
understand that number
but i think that at least when we were
filming i i'm sure darren would agree
with me that
it just kind of felt special you have a
show that's
written by mindy kaling and lang fisher
and you
pair that with an incredible cast and
crew who are so brilliant and talented
you kind of feel this electricity in the
air it's kind of like this unspoken
magic that you can just it's it's
intangible but you can feel it
and i think that we knew it was going to
be something special
the characters are so relatable our show
is so diverse and i think that that's
why so many people around the world
connected with it yeah i agree
um on set you know it was very quick
where it was like wow
this is there's a lot of tree and it's
surprising instead we did not chemistry
and how well everyone played off of each
other and
but you know you always have that i
guess
fear you know the amount of times like
you felt you're making something special
on on a certain set and then you just
don't know how it turns out in the end
and sometimes it's not what you think
this was exactly the opposite of that it
turned out way better than
i even could have could have imagined
and i think the moment though i really
kind of understood like wow it's playing
is
when it was going number one on netflix
in not just the u.s but so many other
countries that was
huge because that's like that's all you
could hope for at that moment you know
when it's
especially when it's so new and fresh um
so yeah
i agree with jared in the sense that we
felt it on set but
you know i'm still kind of trying to
understand it all
and it's uh it's a wonderful experience
yeah because i mean getting a great
pilot script is one thing but then like
you have to get a second episode that's
good and you have to get a second season
script that's good so i would imagine
along the way it's been a lot of like
size of relief yeah
well i'm curious i mean there is
something for everyone in this show and
it's easy to find something to connect
to
what do you most connect to with this is
it
something directly related to your
character or is it something
that related to another one of the
characters on the show um i think for me
it's the messiness of it all i think
that like
high school is messy and sometimes
things don't go the way that you plan
them
and you know people mess up and make
mistakes and
it's painful or you grow from it and
that kind of shapes your identity
and i think that for me that's what the
show is about it's about growing and
learning and creating an identity and
finding yourself
in whatever world that you may live in
and that's what high school was for me
so that's just kind of the comfort
factor there
is is learning about your character and
learning about the relationships that
the other characters have with each
other and kind of seeing all of that
play out in a really funny interesting
heartwarming witty
heartbreaking way that's the reason why
i love this show is just
there is something for everyone no
matter what community you come from
identity that you share there's
something for everybody and i think that
that's super special
yeah messi is the key word it is so
messy and all over the place
and i mean looking back on high school
in general it's like
it's kind of insane how mean
kids can be and how you never know like
how one little whisper can turn into the
biggest rumor
that can really really hurt someone um
so and i think it really sheds light you
know jaren said growth
there's so much growth among characters
but it takes them going through
an absolute mess and some serious
hardship to
experience that growth so i definitely
relate to that i think anyone in high
school
can relate to that um and pretending to
paxton
i think every other character as well um
it's very easy to judge a book by its
cover which i feel like
almost every character in this show is
at first glance
judged by their cover and then you start
to see the layers behind it
so i think it's really important to take
from it you know taking the time
with everyone you meet to look in a
little bit deeper
jared i'm curious while there's this
debbie paxton ben love triangle that
keeps going back and forth throughout
the season ben also
does take a bit of a departure with
anisa
what did you enjoy about getting to
explore that dynamic was it fun
to get to explore a relationship that's
not quite
as contentious absolutely i love world
building and also megan suri is
excellent i think that fans are going to
absolutely love her and love her
character
or if they're extreme team davey maybe
they won't
but i think that it's really fun to get
the chance to explore new relationships
especially for ben anissa represents
something that's really special
is she kind of comes in she immediately
sort of identifies with ben
and takes an interest in him which is
something that he's not used to you know
he comes from an upbringing where his
parents are
really absent and that has a tremendous
effect on his personality
so to have this girl who's effortlessly
cool and so good at so many things takes
such an interest in him and a genuine
care
and kindness towards him is really
special and that's definitely why i
think that initial attraction builds
and then you couple that with again that
inner conflict between okay how does he
still feel about davey and navigating
those feelings
messiness again comes back into play and
that is
high school that's sometimes you're torn
in two different directions so i'm
curious to see if we get a season three
where that ends up going and where he's
pulled
darren i love that we get some moments
this season where paxton actually
wants to not just be seen as
the hot guy but he also wants to show
that he can be smart and
you know be seen on that level too and
then at the same time you also have
kind of a hilarious shirtless scene in
the show
so what was it like to film that moment
is it
difficult to do that and be so serious
is it hard not to crack up when you're
doing something like that
you know what a question
it's i mean he does it so seriously it's
one of my favorite
scenes i literally screamed when i saw
it
this okay i just want to put light on
what mindy mindy sat us all down when
she first booked us and kind of told us
why they earned her her and lang why
they booked us you know and and one of
them was like
darren you know you're one of the only
guys we met that
could smolder but still have a heart and
make it funny
and i take you're talking about the
shirtless scenes
the only funny part about it i mean one
they're playing like pony by genuine in
the background to try and get me in in
the mood of it but also
i'm sprayed down with like glycerin
and and water to make me look sweaty but
it's also inside of a sound stage where
it's like
60 degrees so i'm sitting there trying
not to freeze while i'm also trying to
be sexy so
i'd say that's one of the funniest parts
about it
but yeah i just i kept thinking like the
behind the scenes of that
moment must be fun to watch
yeah yeah they definitely will be
well jared at the end of the season ben
sort of has a realization that losing
davey really sort of is his own fault
and not
paxton's so how do you think he feels
in that moment i think it's so
multi-layered and complex i don't even
know if he genuinely knows what he feels
i think that those feelings with anissa
were true and they were real
and they still are and all of these
feelings of
of pain and of interest and connection
and strength and so many other things
about davey come rushing in all at once
so i think that look is just like this
inner conflict of
what what now what do i do now and also
you can't turn those feelings off and i
think that when
he sees paxton and davey so proudly
dancing together
you know it's just it's hard for him
and i don't think that he knows how to
navigate through that so i think it's
gonna be really interesting to see how
he does come to terms with that
and the the route that he takes in order
to move on or to move
towards it i i'm very curious myself
darren that that moment when davey and
paxton walk into the dance holding hands
and everything after that is such a huge
moment
for them when you get to a moment like
that
is there an added sense of pressure and
responsibility of
making that moment perfect you know for
the show
especially when you know fans are kind
of waiting for that to happen
yeah i mean you want to make that as
perfect as possible um
in that moment i think what added the
pressure was
the range of emotion that you know what
had to be expressed within
you know 10 steps as well as we walk in
because
we're all looking around and and there's
there's a
you know variety of senses of like
approval or disapproval and and you know
i look at my group of friends and
the direction i kept getting like it was
you know like they wanted to see
me kind of like not really knowing how i
felt when i looked at them because
they're obviously all looking me dirty
like how could you
be with this girl who's not on your
level who also cheated on you blah blah
blah blah blah but then also
going back to davey and being confident
holding her hand um so expressing that
was
definitely a challenge because it's as i
said ten steps where you're trying to do
all that
um but yeah i really think
it turned out well i love the
song choice i will not ruin that
surprise but it is
magical and it ties it all together
what would you guys like to see in a
season three is is there anything
involving
your character specifically that you
have like on a personal wish list of
things you'd like to get to explore or
learn more about them
yeah i think it's several things for me
and also
it's weird because a lot of things that
like i wish for
or i don't end up coming true in in
this next season or whatever like for
season one i was like man i wonder if
this will happen and then i'd get
surprised by things i didn't even wish
for that i'm like wow i really
definitely want this in here i'm so glad
that this is there um
but i think for me i love ben's home
life i just i love
getting to work with angela kinsley i
think that she's amazing
um i think that you know it's really
interesting too when we see ben's home
life and then especially the biggest
question now is
again where do we go from here with
ben's relationship with anisa
ben's relationship with davey and just
kind of peeling back some of his layers
again and showing some more of that
vulnerability i really love those types
of scenes
so i'm just i'm really excited if we get
the chance to do a season three kind of
what the writers are going to be cooking
up because
it's so excellent i think you can see
from our transition from season one to
season two
and uh in my opinion it's it's only
gotten better so i can't wait to see if
we get that season three how much better
that we can continue to be
you know season three you you never know
how they're gonna work the timeline but
paxton is a junior you know and he
he may be a senior in season three so
it's going to be interesting seeing
you know what he's deciding to kind of
do
with you know his life after high school
and how he's going to be handling
having to be more academically inclined
and um
[Music]
also and
i going to spoil that i guess right we
can't do that right now
but it's um you know
there there's a lot there to work with
there is a lot of
new in his life that he has to handle
and deal with so
seeing how he tackles that you know
while everything is kind of getting
flip-flop for him
he's had he's been forced to have to try
a lot harder and it's going to be
interesting seeing
how he copes with that and also i love
how they dove in more to his
you know heritage and and home life in
season two
and i think that could even go further
you know maybe a surprise visit from
a cousin in japan like who knows
yeah i love how much fuller all the
characters lives feel i mean we get so
many more
just really sort of private character
moments that there isn't necessarily
time for when you're introducing
everybody in the first season
and i i just i love that because it
makes all the characters lives
feel so much bigger yeah agreed well i
appreciate you guys talking to me i
love this so much it's such a fun show
thank you
thank you so much